♪♪♪
♪ YEAH
YEAH ♪
♪ LOVE THAT GIRL
SHE STAY LOYAL
IN THESE STREETS, CUZ ♪
♪ SOON AS I PULL UP
TO THE CRIB
SHE GETTING KEYED UP ♪
♪ SHE MY MAIN GIRL
I GET HOME SHE GET AT ME
HOP UP ON MY LAP
LIKE WELCOME HOME, DADDY ♪
♪ I LOVE HER
I DON'T EVEN GOT TO FAKE IT
AND WHEN SHE'S AT HOME
SHE LOVES BEING NAKED ♪
♪ SHE'S MY BEST FRIEND
SHE SHOWS LOVE AND RESPECT
THAT'S WHY SHE WALK AROUND
WITH MY NAME ON HER NECK ♪
♪ I LOVE MY BITCH
MY BITCH IS MY DOG
GOOD DOG, GOOD DOG
ONLY DOG, THAT'S ALL ♪
♪ BOW WOW
MY DOG, GOOD DOG
I TALK TO MY DOG
BOW WOW ♪
♪ SHE CUTE SHE BALD
BIG DOG, LITTLE DOG
FAT DOG, SKINNY DOG
ROOF ♪
♪ MY CRANIUM
AND FEED MY POMERANIAN
SHE DOODOO ON MY CARPET
I SAY ♪
>> NO THAT IS NOT WHERE DUTY
GOES.
♪ WOOF WOOF
THAT'S THE CLASSIC SOUND
OF MY PITT
WITH MY BASSET HOUND ♪
♪ IF MY DOG WAS A DOG
THEN I RE-UP
WITH A MINI PEKINESE
IN TEA-CUP ♪
♪ I'M ALLERGIC
TO THESE BITCHES
I TOUCH 'EM
AND START ITCHIN' ♪
♪ IF I SEE IT THEN I PET IT
GET THE DRUGS UP
OUT THE KITCHEN ♪
♪ WOOF WOOF
ZYRTEC AND A BENADRYL
AND A CLARITIN
'CAUSE IT'S GETTING REAL ♪
♪ I LIKE MY DOGS HYPE HYPE
HYPOALLERGENIC ♪
>> WE LOVE DOGS OUT HERE!
YOU THINK THIS IS A [ BLEEP ]
GAME?
YOU SAY SOMETHING ABOUT MY DOG,
I WILL LITERALLY MURDER YOU IN
YOUR FACE!
>> WOAH, WOAH.
HEY, MARK, MAN.
YOU THE DJ.
CHILL, BRO.
CHILL.
THE HELL IS WRONG WITH MARK?
♪ MY DOG
SHE COMES WHEN I CALL
BOW WOW ♪
♪ MY DOG
SILLY DOG
NEW DOG, OLD DOG
BLACK DOG, GOLD DOG ♪
♪ MY DOG NAME IS BRYCE
SHE MY LITTLE POOKIE POOKIE
SHE LOVE A LITTLE HAT ♪
♪ BUT SHE REALLY
LOVE A COOKIE
GOT HER OWN INSTAGRAM
@POOKIE53 ♪
♪ BOW WOW
SOME SAY I RESCUE HER
BUT SHE REALLY RESCUED ME ♪
>> AW, LOOK AT HER LITTLE FACE.
YOU IS A LITTLE BOO BOO IN THE
HAT.
YOU DO GOT A LITTLE HAT ON,
DON'T YOU?
YES YOU DO.
>> RESPECT THIS DOG!
I'MA SHOOT YOU DEAD!
I GOT SHOOTERS IN THE STREETS.
>> YO, MARK, MAN, ENOUGH WITH
THE DEATH THREATS, MAN.
CHILL, BRO.
>> SOMETHING 'BOUT DOGS, MARK.
>> I DON'T LIKE MARK.
>> MARK CRAZY, BRO.
>> YOU BOYS DONE?
I GOT SOMETHING TO SAY.
♪ PUGGIN AND THUGGIN
YEAH THAT'S COOL
BUT THE KISSIN DISGUSTING ♪
♪ I'M KISSING POOKIE
RIGHT NOW
♪ YEAH, BUT I'M WISHIN'
YOU WASN'T
MATTER FACT, I'MA KEEP IT 100
DOGS ARE OKAY ♪
♪ BUT I LOVE ME SOME BUNNIES
HOP HOP
BUNNY, BUNNY, BUNNY
HOP HOP ♪
♪ THERE'S A BUNNY ON MONEY
HOP HOP
FRANKLY I DON'T GIVE
A SHIH-TZU ♪
♪ BUNNIES ARE BETTER
THAN DOGS
IT'S TRUE
IT'S TRUE ♪
>> NOW YOU TALKIN' CRAZY.
♪ MY DOG
BUNNY
DOG DOG DOG DOG
BUNNY HOP BUNNY ♪
♪ SHE CLOSED IT
SHE FALL
MY BEST FRIEND MY DOG
BUNNY, HOE ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]